Vous êtes 6 millions d'abonnés à ma chaîne Youtube ! Merci beaucoup !
Je...je je ne pouvais pas, ne pas faire de vidéo pour vous remercier.
Ce n'est pas concevable.
Vous avez été très très très nombreux à me demander la vidéo : Cyprien répond à vos questions 4.
Et du coup... J'en fais pas...
Vous êtes 6 millions, mais vous ne me connaissez pas tant que ça, du coup on va corriger ça !
Je vous propose, 20 choses sur moi, j'ai pas assez de doigts désolé,
que vous ne connaissez pas, sauf si vous êtes.... ma maman.
Un! J'ai un grain de beauté en plein milieu du front,
ce qui me donne un petit coté hindou,
ou cible de sniper, on sait pas !
Euh, attention t'as un truc sur le front là.
C'est normal, c'est un grain de... *pan*
Je l'avais prévenu, hein, vous êtes témoin...
Deux! J'adore dessiner, c'est une de mes grandes passions dans ma vie.
Je dessine depuis que je sais tenir un crayon.
D'ailleurs, si j'avais pas fait de vidéos, j'aurais probablement fait des petites BD sur internet.
Malheureusement je dessine de moins en moins,
parce que j'ai de moins en moins le temps, ou en tout cas,
je me donne de moins en moins le temps.
Et j'ai ma marque de T-shirts qui me force à être régulier,
à faire des dessins régulièrement.
Trois! Mes parents sont roumains, mais ça j'en parlerai dans une prochaine vidéo.
Quatre! Je suis né à Nice et j'ai grandi dans le Var. Je suis monté sur Paris il y a sept-ans.
Et c'est marrant car à chaque fois que je dis ça, on me dit :
Tiens, c'est marrant, t'as pas l'accent du Sud,
parce que tous ceux qui habitent sous Lyon ont l'accent du Sud !
C'est connu ! Absolument tout le monde sauf toi ! C'est bizarre !
Pas tous les Sudistes ont un accent, voilà comme ça, c'est dit !
Puis, personnellement, avec des parents qui ont un accent Roumain,
c'est compliqué de choper un accent du Sud...
Ou alors un accent du Sud de la Roumanie grand max.
Cinq! J'adore les jouets !
Quand je rentre dans un magasin de jouets pour offrir un truc à un enfant.
Je suis comme ça...
*dans sa tête* : N’achète rien, n’achète rien...
Je veux le Buzz l'éclair géant s'il vous plait !
Monsieur, c'est une statue de deux mètres elle n'est pas à vendre.
*insistant* Je la veux ! MAINTENANT !
Six! Je ne peux pas manger de poisson ou de fruits de mer.
Si on m'en fait manger, je fais ça :
*vomit*
Même l'odeur ça me suffit parce que si je passe devant une poissonnerie...
Même juste parler de poisson...
*vomit*
Là, j’exagère un peu... c'est vrai...
Seeept! Mon deuxième prénom...
j'en ai pas...voilà.
Souvent les deuxièmes prénoms c'est des prénoms bien moches, bien nuls...
Moi, mes parents ils ont pensé à me mettre directement un deuxième prénom.
Merci papa.. merci maman..
Huiiiit! Il est vrai que j'ai un petit peu de mal avec la cuisine.
Si vous me regardez cuisiner, c'est assez triste...
Oh m*rde... pu*in...
Neuf! Attention, je sais faire ça :
*acclamations*
Et aussi ça :
Et également ça :
*acclamations*
Merci beaucoup !
Dix! Je... n'ai pas... le permis !
*Huée*
Oui, bon ça va, c'est assez humiliant comme ça, on va pas en rajouter... merci...
Je sais pas pour toi mais moi je suis super nerveux au volant, je suis super nerveux...
Mais tout pareil on me le dit, Jean-Louis, Jean-Louis, t'es nerveux au volant !
Voilà, tout le monde me le dit !
Exactement ! Dès que je suis au volant, comme ça, je suis au volant, paf je suis nerveux!
Et toi Cyprien ?
Ah ben moi... Moi c'est pareil, moi c'est vraiment pareil, heu...
Je suis super nerveux...
... à la place passager...
Est-ce que quelqu'un peut me ramener ce soir ?... peut être ?...
Je serai pas nerveux place passager...
Onze! J'ai une cicatrice sur le crâne.
Je me suis fait ça en tombant par terre quand j'avais cinq ans.
C'était très douloureux, j'ai eu des points de suture et tout...
Et je vous propose une petite reconstitution...
Douze! Je suis capable de passer des journées entières sur mon ordinateur ou mon téléphone,
même s'il ne se passe rien !
Rien sur Twitter... rien sur Facebook... rien sur Insta... rien sur Snapchat...
Rien dans ma vie, à part ce petit point rouge qui vient d'appar... *pan*
Treize! Je connais le chiffre π (Pi) 8 chiffres après la virgule...
Ça ne sert à rien,
sauf si vous jouez à qui veut gagner des millions et qu'on vous pose la question, vous m'appelez !
Mon numéro c'est le 03 14 15 92 65 (ou 3,14159265)
Quatorze. Quand j'étais petit, mon doudou c'était pas une peluche ou un chiffon ou... nan.
C'était un oreiller,
que je trimbalais absolument partout.
Et à un moment j'ai arrêté parce que ça commençait à devenir contraignant...
Ouais les mecs, on fait quoi ce soir ? On va en boîte ? Eh ben c'est parti !
Quinze! Quand j'étais gamin, j'étais amoureux de Ondine
du dessin animé Pokémon, oui j'étais amoureux d'un dessin animé !
C'est pour ça que je ne vais pas dans des conventions avec des cosplayeuses d'ailleurs !
Eh, salut !
*voix bidon* J'ai treize ans.
Au revoir !
Seize! J'adore qu'on me masse le crâne, mais vraiment,
dès qu'on me touche la tête, même le visage, ça m'endort immédiat...
*ronfle*
Attend, mais elle sent le poisson ta main !
*vomit*
Dix-sept! J'ai un problème avec la paperasse,
dès qu'il faut envoyer un truc par la poste,
vous pouvez être sûr que je ne le ferai JAMAIS !
Ça va traîner toute une vie sur mon bureau !
Je suis tellement fainéant, que c'est un pote à moi qui a envoyé les papiers à ma place,
pour faire ma carte Navigo !
Dix-huit! Ma toute première vidéo postée sur internet,
c'était un test de jeu vidéo !
Wenden, vous savez pas ce que c'est? Ben ça tombe bien, je suis là pour vous expliquer.
C'est un jeu Nintendo DS...
Ma deuxième vidéo postée sur Internet, c'était une musique,
avec un pote dans le garage chez mes parents.
Et ma dernière vidéo postée sur Internet, c'est celle-ci !
*acclamations*
Dix-neuf... ouais...
Je m'attache pas aux objets même si c'est des cadeaux,
ou des vêtements, dès que ça ne me sert à rien,
ou dès que j'en ai marre, je le donne ou je le jette.
Et voilà !
Mais le pire, c'est les boîtes, vous voyez, ceux qui gardent leurs boîtes de tablettes ou de téléphones,
vous peut être, je sais pas, moi je ne comprends pas, hein.
C'est le premier truc que je jette !
Cyprien, tu sais ou il est le carton de mon ordinateur ?
Ah t'inquiète pas je m'en suis occupé ce matin, je l'ai jeté.
Il y avais mon ordinateur dedans...
euh...
C'est quoi ce point rouge sur mon... *pan*
Et vingt. Je collectionne les fausses vidéos de moi sur Youtube,
dès que j'en vois une, je fais un screenshot.
En fait, c'est des mecs qui se font passer pour moi sur Youtube,
et qui postent de fausses vidéos juste pour faire du clic.
Voici mon top trois des vidéos que je n'ai jamais faite :
*tousse*
En troisième position, "Cyprien - Les Chats PERVERS",
avec 1,3 millions de vues, pas mal !
Deuxième position, "Cyprien - Les Roux", avec 1,7 millions de vues.
On notera la description : "Tetris, cédérom vidéo de 2PM".
Si quelqu'un a une explication à ça...
Et ma vidéo préférée que je n'ai jamais réalisée, "Cyprien - Les Seins Tueurs",
avec seulement 766 000 vues, mais mention spéciale pour le nom de la chaîne :
Beyoncé Cyprien...
Le mec s'est dit : "C'est sûr, là ça va double cliquer, en plus les gens pensent que c'est la même personne"...
"Ça va cliquer !"...
Voilà, maintenant, vous savez tout sur moi.
Je vous remercie encore de vous être abonné à ma chaîne.
Depuis le garage de chez mes parents jusqu'à aujourd'hui,
je prends toujours autant de plaisir à faire des vidéos.
J'ai encore plein de trucs à vous raconter
et pour moi vous êtes les meilleurs abonnés du monde.
Merci beaucoup !
Par contre, vous avez un petit point rouge sur le front juste...*pan*
Sous-titres : Par Redall
Les sous-titres peuvent avoir des erreurs, merci de nous les faire parvenir dans les commentaires !